[Music]
reasons as to why a shinobi no mono
should be employed
[Music]
he must have five basic elements loyalty
courage strategy achievement including
worthy deeds and fidelity and on top of
these a healthy body
he must be gentle at normal times and
have a keen sense of righteousness but
little need of desires he needs to be
fond of learning the principles of
things and to never forget his
indebtedness to others
he must be fluent in speech deep in
thought quick in communicating with
people at normal times and difficult to
deceive especially by using logic to
avoid falling for smooth-talking traps
he should know heavens will and have a
grasp of Confucianism and Buddhism and
be always aware that life and death have
their determined appointment he must aim
at rising above his own self-interest at
all times and bear the words of ancient
sages in mind he should be earnest to
know the morals of the samurai class and
furthermore should learn much about the
ways of Japanese and Chinese ancient
warriors who had loyalty and bravery
dedicated themselves to their Lord and
destroyed the enemy with tactics and all
in the service of their Lord also he
should have great interest in military
affairs or the arts of war his
temperament should be that of a hero
usually he should not be argumentative
with people he must be gentle and
dignified and above this have a name as
being righteous and good within or
outside of his domain he should be
reputed to be completely honest
his wife children and relatives must be
of good descent thus there should be
little chance that he could be a
reversed shinobi he must be well
traveled and have a good knowledge of
what the manners and customs are like in
various provinces he must study hard and
learn deeply the art of shinobi no jutsu
be competent in strategy be talented at
writing skilled in all areas of ninjutsu
to the highest degree and aspire to
perform merits in battle as well as
Military Affairs he must also be
accomplished in various arts be poetic
musical knowing how to dance have the
ability to impersonate others and be
proficient in all other activities and
can use them to make up for any
situation without blundering
those who have the above 10
characteristics very rare and should be
called John in or highly skilled ninja
it is difficult to find a John in as
mentioned above unless the Lord has
profound wisdom and completely
understands people just as if he can see
into their mind if he is not a sage he
cannot attain the status of John in
sunsoo says only those who are wise will
be able to employ spies usefully
[Music]
you
[Music]